I'm here we're doing this today
there you go
[Music]
stop
hey let's understand the conion points
okay so he does his move forget that
part okay here he is and at Dynamic
speed he's going to hit my hands you
see so I got to get to the other side so
we'll do it embryonic so I can talk if
you can he's going to come down my
weapon you see boom hit my hand when he
he's not you can see he's not all the
way into the atos he has been dropped to
Center as far as he wants and the tip
hasn't parallel to the ground so if I
stay up you see now it's contesting
continually with my hands it'll hit my
should shoulders and it'll pull me down
when it stops I'll keep going okay and
I'm pinned he draws move and I'm hit
okay so I have to reconcile all of these
things okay okay here we are so the
first one is when he starts to come down
I turn my weapon my hands out of the way
you see the next one is I don't stay up
I blend with him so he doesn't check my
height I'm here not pushing up but not
breaking off because I didn't contested
I'm stuck to it okay when he goes to
draw right I'm going to stay stuck to
it
boom and then come around do you see
okay it's not that he goes here
I get my hands hit I get my go thrown
and then I'm supposed to come here I'm
going to stick to his weapon by
yielding so we go a little
smooth boom
off and out okay try it again
[Music]
so again looking at the contention
points
okay boom WI
there's going to be friction here I
cannot just go I cannot go like
that he's going to have his adhesion
that's why you
draw okay so when he comes down I have
to
yield I don't keep my shoulders up in
contention with his downward and try to
go around that
my shoulders draw with
him you
see his hand hits my
sword you
see not my
sword hits his hand okay second
thing he
goes what about
that there's no reason why he has to
draw the Joel back
you see as I go to cut and he stabs boom
this iuchi
so you have to
move off the line off the line you see
here over
here you
drop and you have to move your feet
you
drop you see he hits your weapon you cut
through okay try it again